Sam John Connor at the beginning of
salvation yeah dude dude guys we got a
special video we're gonna watch today I
don't really know what it is Jared and
Jensen share stories from Supernatural
you see over at our patreon plug time
over her patreon we do weekly Q&A Xand
we also do a TV show reaction stream
along this we could sync up timecode
included and those are Cobra Kai season
2 haunting of Hill House Gotham stranger
thing season 3 agents of shield and then
there are several shows where we have
stream along and we do reaction
highlights for them as well so you have
to worry about the syncing up portion
the main one that people come to is
supernatural we are almost done with
season 3 right now and then we have
other shows that we do attack on Titan
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood my hero
academia movie included Death Note Code
Geass one punch man hunter hunter but
main one is supernatural that's what
most people are therefore we have a
patron Ashley Webber all the way from
New Zealand who has specifically put
this together just for us to react to
you and I was like thanks because we're
afraid to always look up stuff about
supernatural because it's been around
for so long it's easy to get stuff
ruined so this is just Jared and Jensen
shares stories from Supernatural and I
just sounds like a fun video for us to
check out Thank You Ashley
Oh Jerry because besides that's science
yeah so it's that makes it sound like
they're saying that so they just move
east Sam auditions they were not there
it was like hey everybody come into
these same scenes as the character Sam
and we'll see if we like you for this
you for that that's what this gentleman
- well yes I think it is items dangers
think they wanted to give their there
Sam first and then start reading for
deeds and start looking for deeds but
they invited a few people in to read
force and they just wanted to see as
potential deeds but they weren't
releasing evil deeds dialogue so
everybody would read the same publishes
see and it was a Sam scene and so I went
in there you know Sam's the main
character
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that that might be a little bit more it
by a bill house and focal David Nutter
and if you were sitting right there
going we succeeded set up the reading
that's already I read the part of Sam
but it was more above general audition
and then I never came back and brethren
even infect the next time the next time
in vision was it was the final audition
[Applause]
[Music]
and that's it I wouldn't change anything
else what was the first experience our
experience like yes I need a
supernatural yeah so like when we met
for the first time kind of thing yeah I
[Music]
was like wow this guy is really tall and
skinny and I was like wow this guy's
handsome brother
[Laughter]
yeah
[Music]
that's yeah that's one of the earlier I
think I don't remember getting the
script originally but I'm her reading
through it and being like ah you know at
the time my charm was on Angel and maybe
Buffy was still on and those are all
great shows but not the show I wanted to
do next in my career I was like wow fine
but I wanted something a little prettier
and more real a little bit kind of like
gnarlier and they wouldn't listen this
is not gonna be a show about like the
goofy aspects of science fiction it's
gonna be kind of gritty like x-files I
was like all right cool
send it to me let me read it and I read
it I was like this this gets asked like
we should we should definitely go after
this
and so having it power we show up but
usually we use my addition it's a it's a
terrifically anxiety-inducing process
and you usually walk in and it's like
all the guys you kind of look like you
know within five years of your age
either way through that way a lot of
them have a lot more experience and
they're all talking about like this role
they just did or that thing they know
it's a mortifying just really
dehumanizing experience that's when we
get there and I'm like okay every person
who I've ever seen on a TV show or movie
that's my age is gonna be they're
auditioning for this pilot because it
was the big one of those pilot and so I
show up in Johnny hands walks and
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that my question was where's
everybody else
are you for saying but you know
everything Reaper saying so where's
everybody else
the other ten actors that are that are
fighting for this job right fighting for
his role and know whatever show that and
then they ask the two of us to come back
we read together for the first time ever
in front of 30 executives and Warner
Brothers and and when I told that I was
scared of the thing in my closet 45
[Laughter]
[Applause]
it was what was he supposed to do
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
because my shoe everybody's obviously
telling you how tall you all are and so
it's trying to get have you get that
height inside the camera box in the
creative ways that because I've noticed
like the pairings Jared it co-stars have
been getting shorter
[Laughter]
just like Jared's chess in the top of
his head hey we know where the ratings
are right yeah the hair has a lot of the
shorter characters that we've had on the
show they they build with them people in
Vancouver referred to as jewel boards so
Jilly boards Jilly Ward's which are like
quarter Apple boxes those are an Apple
box well Coover a lot of the crews work
on our show and a lot of other shows
were around during the x-files days on
xbox because was so hyped deprived build
like runways for her to walk on so that
she wouldn't you know even out with
David the rest of the cast and they just
became known as Jilly boards as Juliet's
do it now so they still the crew the
crews in Vancouver still refer to
building a little like quarter Apple for
actors or actresses to walk on has Julie
Ward's so that is how they kind of Eve
playing field with lurch and myself are
all rule in season one was that anytime
jetsons had to stand on an Apple box he
got to punch me because he was like dude
I'm always the tallest guy on set I
don't like this I stand on a box top
raise your gun for anybody
so either shrink or you're getting
punched it seems like I could understand
that sure but yeah there's there's a lot
of there's a lot of platform building
underneath a lot of these people and
it's funny - these will get you know
will get a good sized guy coming on to
guest star and it'll be really upset
come on be like come on get it like that
or the B's hey guys make sure you're not
allergic to bees like shot what actually
we're just gonna take this beans
[Laughter]
it's only a three-quarter steam
I'm not kidding so they put this little
piece of mesh on your skin and then they
hold a live with tweezers scissors and
then they just stick the sticker and it
goes just through the match enough to
get like half its stinger in you and
then they pull it out it doesn't come
off the base of the be spine but but I'm
not because now I just got started by a
baby now I pick on my arm and they're
like okay it's been 30 minutes you're
fine okay except for this you know
glitter on my arm huh oh so funny
because they passed institution-wide new
stuff on supernatural you know jump out
of this window don't worry they can see
but there's going to be a pattern and
I'll end on 12 feet down cool like uh
spin this corn to a 360 and then you're
finding this guy ran your head through
that wall it's like okay guys time to go
into set and we walk in all of the crew
have B outfits on
[Music]
regular clothing and in the beep
Wrangler there okay okay stay calm wait
a minute
with the yell action I support used to
say we gots done I guess just before Kim
our director just before he yelled
action they were like okay roll sound
and I'll be there all over the place
real sound okay you know the cameras it
comes up it's like okay 34 Baker take
two they said have a worker they run off
and I'm like kind of crouched down and
I'm like kind of flicking these just
about to be there on me just landing on
me and I'm like gosh fine I have a place
find a happy face
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a set built sort of spit column
and we climbed up to the top and we
there were cameras up there so we
started climbing down this little batter
in a tube and I went first
the journey was coming right right down
on top of me basically and that it was
just a wall of water from up top and it
was the camera guys at two five-gallon
buckets of cold water on top of those
courtesy of Kim man there's our director
at the time I remember producer coming
up to me just before the shot obviously
he was in on it
because he was like hey no problem
that's good sweet oh oh you really did
just make this video specifically for us
to react to oh thank you so much I love
this so much
yeah what you know a supernatural yell a
supernatural you like that a Concord
zeroD pedal lucky Jensen Ackles this is
exactly my kind of video mm-hmm this is
the kind of video I watch on my own time
just looking up my favorite actors
actresses celebrity interviews panels
time flew by for me on this cuz I was
like this is Jen generally something I
would probably just watch on my own time
yeah but like I said because of the fact
that it's supernatural I don't look up
these interviews because I'm afraid so
they get ruined as they were like
talking about specific episodes I'm like
oh yeah we covered it oh yeah Ashley
went out of her way to make sure we like
really made sure that it was like a okay
for us that nothing would get ruined cuz
that's one thing that I often think
about actually is the fact that I can't
like it I wish you know some kind of
version of time had worked out where we
could have followed along from the
beginning and maybe gotten to experience
what some of these conventions are like
and just see some of this in real time
because yeah you want to go and seek out
the behind the scenes stories and the
moments of them just being off-the-cuff
talking about the show and so yeah this
was really nice to get that it's
hilarious on the one hand but I also
kind of learned some stuff we've got
like a really in-depth look at how it is
to work with bees yeah yeah when they
were saying they were real bees it was
throwing me off because I remember that
moment really thinking they're all CGI
bees and you speculate that might be
enhanced but it's that's it completely
is digital add all of that in there
unfortunately like I'm sure they may be
through in some inserts or whatever but
yeah it's like that scene where they're
all swatting it blows my mind how long
all these big shows or even big movies
that actors will still have no matter
how much
money they have their production budget
safety precautions and a lot of the
physical dangers they have to put up
with like the actors themselves they
still have to deal with so much of that
crap it really like I love to share
their super protected super safe but
they still got a deal with a lot of
strenuous thing they give you this weird
B test now
and you even got an insight into Kim
manners his mind set on things because
you never rarely hear I would see Kim
Mathers name pop up on the directed by a
note Kim has passed away in recent years
I'm always fascinated by whatever
episode K matters directing to get some
insight and see like the humorous side
of them he's the one who put together
the prank of the water I remember that
bit and then glad nobody slipped yeah
you Jared falling on top of Jensen like
he's still big weak really bad the whole
thing with the leaves and sitting down
shorts like let's just handle this
direct from right here that like that's
leadership right there it's like if you
guys are in here I'll be in here - I was
on a short film set and as harsh as the
conditions were when it was like 115
degrees and we were like people who were
literally passing out of getting a
hospital life whatever we had to
interact with the director or something
I just wouldn't complain because it was
like you've got so many more things to
worry about and I got worried about my
one job so I can totally imagine how a
director could get like impatient and be
like suck it up let's go you're an actor
for come on yeah sounds like based on
where you were saying what we were
acting that you are aware of how tall
they were I would always assume that
Jerry palicky was like 6 1 and then
Jensen Ackles was like 5 9 or something
okay yeah then I hear he's above sea
scale that up a little bit why I didn't
expect Jensen Ackles to be above 6 feet
yeah because of the way they frame the
show that he doesn't look like he's six
feet like don't like a JPEG he looks
clearly over six feet tall Jensen Ackles
looks like we'd be the same hider at
least because I'm 510 that must trip you
out when someone is that but you're
ready and hey I mean it's perfect match
like that also blew my mind I wasn't a
hundred percent clear on the context the
idea that like a bunch of people didn't
even show
- that one callback or whatever and then
they wound up reading the next time for
the studio like it seems as though we
got really lucky to live in the universe
where these two dudes happen to wander
into this audition you know Jer
padalecki was saying they were
originally just casting for Sam Sam's
this is like the main character they
were hyper focused on was Sam that's
funny because well since we got him
season 3 we've been talking about how
Dean seems to be the main character that
season no the first season with Sam was
like the main characters and then he's
Dean holed into this work team was like
though the scene stealer but literally
the support yeah yeah yeah he's here to
show you the ropes that is funny how it
all worked out in the fact that they did
have enough commonality enough rapport
being both being from Tech's I didn't
know where any other front both being
from texts that's both having the same
you know we've gone for Dallas Cowboys
right that's a team dance accountable
it's a soccer
Texas into oh yeah yeah football is they
college here I saw both being in the
country music man I go for one love
these guys you should definitely have
her meet then we really lucked out
because that brotherly dynamic is
incredibly there and then even seeing
the way they they act onstage it just
makes me think like when we watch the
show Johnson and I are always like yeah
I'm definitely Dean you're saying yeah
and then watch them interviews I'm like
yeah I can look like when I'm listening
like I'm not that interested it was
being yet but then I participated I'm
like oh I really am in case my very
thoughtful answer because I notice my
listening or I come in with it just a
really sarcastic comment yes I noticed
that Jensen Ackles gonna look
disinterested but really he is yeah
criticism towards me often too he's just
listening man yeah and then going in the
story telling a long-haired guy yeah
yeah
we are them you are the brothers that's
what we're dressing as for Halloween
this year we are the Winchester brothers
just a much lesser scale of masculinity
yeah you know we'll get there you're
masculine enough for the two of us
actually funny story about the bees that
ring me think of when I was on set not
the bees it's true what they're saying
about doing stunts and stuff it's like
you how you get so any character for
these things in the short film I was in
the same partner I had for the last day
of shooting we had these guns we got
some gun training or supposed to be
shooting at bad guys right whatever
don't ruin it for you and we got so into
it it's like 115 degrees we're in this
like military tent we both got our pulse
up and like to keep the intensity going
or like doing push-ups or boom breathing
heavy we are in it we are like focused
like we got it like we're so in it we're
just waiting for that action actually
take and then I became and then action
was called to be like badass shooting at
bad guys or whatever and like I'm
supposed to be like in charge of this
operation we're in it so we both just
lost it we're like those Apple boxes Tom
Cruise uses those mm-hmm
jillee boards Tom Cruise heavily relies
on them yeah yeah that in those
platforms Tom Cruise really four foot
eight he has costly being propped up on
many things he's always on top of a ramp
he's got just a special ramp that he's
like they build it into every place he
appears for half of his the budget of
the movies go to don't worry when they
have femur implants available Tom Cruise
will be first when Peter Jackson had to
learn how to do the Hobbit effects so
unlike Lord of the Rings the size
comparison he just went on a Tom Cruise
say every Mission Impossible is hard to
shoot because we got all these forces
that would be so this was great Thank
You Ashley for putting this together as
actually just for us I did in real I
thought this was just one of your videos
and you were like yeah I'll wait to
release it after you guys but I didn't
realize made this just for us thank you
thank you so much you're so sweet guys
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification Bell check us on
patreon come watch Supernatural this
bunch of other shows if you want mean
the supernatural see you guys